the city i live in this little village
of the present but lately i forget my
neighbors names more and more i spend my
days in the city the great metropolis
where i can hope to glimpse great
spirits as they cross the street sold
durable as the cockroach and the
lungfish when i was young i lived in a
different village we had parades the
circus the nearby fort and rabbi gewirtz
invented a game called baseball to reach
first base you had to chant two lines of
Hebrew verse correctly mistakes were
outs one strike for every stammer or
hesitation we boys were thankful for our
rabbis grace his balancing the immensity
of words written in letters of flame by
God himself with our mere baseball
little things we knew or do i
misremember did we boys think there were
no girls that baseball was the city and
that the language we were learning by
rote a little attention to meaning now
and then was small and local the major
leagues the city one of the boys was
killed a few years later wearing a
uniform thousands of miles away he was a
stupid boy when I was captain I somehow
he managed to read his way to first I
never let him attempt the next two lines
to stretch it to a double so long ago
sometimes I think I've never seen the
city that where I've been is just a
shabby district where I persuade myself
I'm at the center or atrocities
beheadings mass executions troops
ordered to rape and humiliate the news
the Psalms the epics what if that's the
gewirtz he told us means a dealer in
spices annison margerum used for
preserving corpses for preserving or
enhancing food and drink the stuff of
civilization like games and versus the
other night I dreamed about that boy the
foolish one who died in the course of
war he pulled his chair up so he faced
the wall I wanted him to read from the
prayer book he didn't answer he wouldn't
play the game